on va retrouver tout de suite notre
envoyé spécial à kiev sylvain rousseau
bonjour à vos sylvain sur le terrain il
ya donc désormais de véritables
difficultés à acheminer l'aide
humanitaire
oui effectivement et alors il ya deux
sortes d'aidé humanitaire il ya les
aides humanitaires qui proviennent des
gouvernements et puis celles qui
proviennent des organisations non
gouvernementales c'est celle ci qui sont
plus difficiles à acheminer sa demande à
une véritable logistique on a pu voir à
la frontière polonaise lorsque nous
sommes passés entre entre la pologne et
l'ukraine qui l'y a énormément d'eau ong
qui sont présentes sur place mais très
peu arrivent à passer la frontière à
acheminer de l'aide humanitaire vers la
frontière et plus encore vers la ville
de kiev 1 il faut rappeler que la route
que nous avons prises nous hier pour
rejouer pour venir de lviv à kiev était
encore fermé impraticable il y a
quelques jours les camions d'aidé
humanitaire qui arrivent doivent d'abord
tout décharger à la frontière est
récupéré par des chauffeurs ukrainien
puis doivent à nouveau tout décharger à
lviv à 80 km de la frontière pour être
acheminés sur kiev par ben tout
simplement sous comptes sous escorte de
l'armée ukrainienne tout ça demande une
logistique extrêmement compliqué elles
sont très peu à arriver jusque là et
pourtant il y a des vrais besoins
notamment en médicaments en trousse de
premier secours ont beaucoup de choses
comme ça les hôpitaux comme celui de
devant lequel je me trouve à kiev
manquements cruellement de 2,2 tout de
quoi pratiquer en fait les premiers
soins aux patients entre entre la la
blessure et le moment où ils vont être
pris en charge par les hôpitaux c'est
vraiment ça qui manque le plus et c'est
effectivement pour l'instant très
compliqué d'acheminer tout ça sur la
capitale ukrainienne une situation qui
ne devrait pas se faciliter un
s'arranger notamment avec l offensive
qui se concentre désormais sur l'est
oui effectivement vous l'avez dit juste
avant juge juste avant la ville denis
proulx a été bombardé l'aéroport est
sous le feu des bombes russe également
lui depuis depuis quelques heures
maintenant on attend en fait la grande
offensive russe pour le pour le pour le
contrôle du dombass les russes qui
[Musique]
ce
qu'on craint en fait surtout en ukraine
c'est que cette offensive soit
extrêmement longue il faut savoir que
les ukrainiens profitent non pas de
cette accalmie puisqu'il ne s'agit pas
d'accalmie mais de cette réorganisation
des troupes russes pour eux aussi
renforcer la première heure pour aussi
renforcé leurs positions par dont les
armements sont acheminés désormais vers
l'est de l'ukraine et puis on va se
retrouver dans une situation avec deux
armes et à peu près équivalente en
l'ombre et les ukrainiens qui ont des
positions qui sont déjà prêtes la guerre
pour le dombass a en vérité commencer en
2014 et ukrainiens sont prêts ils ont
sur place leurs meilleurs soldats ils
ont sur place la meilleure arme ils ont
creusé des tranchées ils sont ils
attendent en fait quelque part les
russes et effectivement on craint ici
énormément de victimes d'autant plus
qu'on l'a vu il n'ya pas longtemps à la
gare de crest à manosque et bien les
missiles les missiles russes empêche
également la plupart des civils de
s'enfuir et là encore l'aide humanitaire
faire parvenir cette aide humanitaire
est encore plus compliqué dans ces zones
là alors qu'elle est encore plus urgente
à sylvain rousseau envoyé spécial de
france 24 en ukraine merci avoue sylvain
pour tout s'explique